[Música]
y comenzamos nuestra sección dedicada a
la información de salud hoy vuelve a
nuestros estudios más romeros a la mar
un placer estar con usted lo mismo digo
que maría claro bueno y el domingo se
conmemoró el día mundial de la salud
sexual con motivo de este día hablamos
precisamente del crecimiento de las
enfermedades de transmisión sexual en
los últimos años así es maría clara son
unas cifras que de hecho llegan a pesar
de la pandemia de kobe 19 no que nos
hubieran hecho pensar que los múltiples
aislamientos habrían reducido estas
cifras pero no es así hay un crecimiento
de varias enfermedades de transmisión
sexual en diversos países estados
unidos-españa también a argentina y sin
olvidar que la salud sexual va mucho más
allá de los contagios y de las
enfermedades hoy vamos a abordar este
fenómeno con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez él es médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia es un
gusto volver a saludarlo y tenerlo aquí
con nosotros en directo américas doctor
cuéntenos cómo explicamos que hayan
crecido las enfermedades de transmisión
sexual
a la mar miren la enfermedad transmisión
sexual siempre han sido prevalentes en
la manía de sonar las grandes desafíos
que tenemos como médicos probablemente
haya un mejor registro de estas
enfermedades la gente consulta más y si
se ha visto un incremento notorio sobre
todo en europa y en norteamérica donde
hay más estadísticas acerca del ínter
tema en donde se ha incrementado en
todas las poblaciones tanto hombres o
mujeres estas enfermedades esto es algo
que nos preocupa y que tenemos que
enfrentar probablemente con estrategias
educativas pero por ahora llevando más
al diagnóstico y consultando más
tempranamente a los maridos doctor
bienvenido de nuevo france24 y a una
pregunta que si bien algunas personas ya
conocen la respuesta es importante
enfatizar de nuevo que es una enfermedad
de transmisión sexual
y aclara lo que hace la ley es el
mecanismo y cómo se adquiere la
enfermedad las enfermedades se adquieren
por varios mecanismos por ejemplo por
vía respiratoria como lo que pasa con el
codo y por vía sanguínea por vía
alimentaria y hay algunas que se
adquieren por vía es sexual no
exclusivamente por vía sexual ya estas
enfermedades que se pueden adquirir a
través del semen del fluido vaginal de
las relaciones pene atractivas son y el
contacto íntimo es las que llamamos que
tiene un mecanismo de enfermedad de
transmisión sexual ésta se agrupa en una
gran serie de enfermedades son por lo
menos un par de decenas de enfermedades
que se puede adquirir por esta vía y
estas enfermedades se contextualizan no
hacia exclusivamente la relación sexual
pero si hace parte es un mecanismo de
adquisición que además es importante
recordar esto también con las
confusiones que ha habido alrededor de
la viruela del mono así tenemos las las
definiciones al menos claras conocemos
mucho por ejemplo el vih no entre de
enfermedades que estaba nombrando pero
es que la verdad el mayor crecimiento ha
venido de otro tipo de enfermedades por
ejemplo clamidia sífilis también
gonorrea
en los grupos más vulnerables población
el eje de población afrodescendiente
cómo afrontamos esto cómo le damos una
solución
definitivamente aquí es una pregunta
simple con una respuesta muy compleja
porque no es solamente la parte médica
es la parte de salud pública el mayor
registro la pedagogía y el contexto
social en donde estas enfermedades dejen
de estigmatizarse como unas enfermedades
de algunos grupos o que están
relacionadas con algunas prácticas
sexuales para saber qué es una
enfermedad humana y que necesitamos
enfrentarlos todas entre todos y muchas
de esas enfermedades pueden ser de
cables algunas como hepatitis b por
ejemplo tiene vacuna y puede ser
perfectamente prevenible pero editamos
mucha más pedagogía dejar de segmentar a
que tenga que ver con alguna
estigmatización en las relaciones
sexuales para poder enfrentar más
francamente y buscarles una solución
porque las hay ahí tienen tratamiento
hay algunas vacunas tienen muchas más
vacunas y por eso necesitamos que la
gente sea ciencia y dice y hablar de
estos temas pues nos permite poder
decirle a la gente que se acerque a los
sistemas de salud y que no tengan miedo
al estigma o algún tipo de prevención
por la orientación sexual por ejemplo
pero también hay otro evento teoría es
que hay enfermedades que se creían ya
desaparecidas como la sífilis sin
embargo se están volviendo a ver cuáles
son las consecuencias de su reaparición
la civil es una enfermedad que hemos
enfrentado por siglos una enferma
histórica no digamos que nunca a
principios del siglo pasado de hace dos
siglos era una enfermedad altamente
prevalente ahora lo es lo que pasa es
que tengo una herramienta como la
penicilina que la hace tratable y es una
enferma 100% curable si se diagnostica
tempranamente lo que pasa es que las
utiliza una enfermedad que llamamos la
gran simuladora por que semeja varias
enfermedades o muchas veces pasa
perfectamente asintomática y durante
unos años se transmite es decir que tú
no reconoces que esa persona tenga
sífilis tienes una relación sexual
porque no tiene ninguna lesión aparente
y esta persona te puede contagiar eso lo
que hace es que esta enfermedad sea
desafiante porque se transmite en
personas asintomáticas y simulan muchas
enfermedades doctor muy rápidamente hay
algunas voces que atribuyen este repunte
a que se habla más abiertamente del sexo
cuál es el mensaje no debería ser
precisamente al revés
totalmente tenemos que hablar de
educación sexual tenemos que fortalecer
los sistemas de salud sexual sana y
reproductiva tenemos que hablar en los
colegios hablar de las universidades
hablar en las familias y hablar
abiertamente de los métodos de
protección recuerden que hay vacunas
como la de vph y hepatitis bay que
protegen para enfermedad de transmisión
sexual el vih tiene alternativas de
tratamiento para la prevención y son una
gran cantidad de herramientas tenemos
que hablar francamente y tenemos que
todo lo contrario ser mucho más abiertos
para poder buscar soluciones entre todos
comunidad médicos ciencia y medios de
comunicación y precisamente en el papel
de los medios de comunicación estamos
aquí ayudando a informar sobre las
enfermedades sexuales doctor carlos
eduardo pérez gracias por estar con
nosotros
y gracias a usted también por
acompañarnos con este tema tan
interesante por supuesto clara y
nosotros seguimos con más noticias en
directo américa